pop and chips ou country food gypsum pop
Je suis accro à la
country food avez-vous comme un
country food préféré terrible moi daba lucre avec de la
sauce soja ça me garde plus fort et
beaucoup plus d'énergie mais j'aime quand même la
jonction il ne manque pas de nourriture maintenant
les gens ne savent pas quels aliments sont de bons
choix nous trompons les mères pour qu'elles ne donnent pas de
malbouffe quand elles sont petites était difficile
avec ma fille de six ans et cette dame a
commencé à lui donner des boissons gazeuses alors qu'elle était
encore dans mon sac nous ne pouvons pas y aller
sans nourriture de campagne, nous pouvons mener la nourriture au miel et aux noix
du magasin, mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour les gens que mes parents aiment surtout moi la
nourriture qu'ils ne vivront pas nous vivons dans le nord
où il fait très froid en hiver la
nourriture de campagne d'Eden nous garde au chaud
j'aime  à la fois unique et coupé votre pas de nourriture
j'aime ça parce que ça sent bon
le seul petit-enfant ne mange pas de viande
il est né végétarien